we're gonna put snail [ __ ] on our face
guys it's okay whatever it takes to get
beautiful stache
[Music]
it's overwhelming how many products
there are yeah I've heard of some like
snail products where you use like this
slime of this snail to put on your face
and it's supposed to make your skin
smoother or something like that is that
what we're trying today it wasn't
actually oh no I love new skincare stuff
I do too
at earth no smell no slime all right how
do you collect this much snail slime
like how many snails did you have to
follow it is what I picture that is just
like a little like milk in a snail yeah
if I can recall correctly playing with
snails as a young child it will be slimy
and cold I just fixed her those like
cartoon snails with that like trail of
like [ __ ] behind them you know what I
mean and then it's like wipe it up and
put it on your face that's what they're
telling you today pretty much I'm
nervous about the smell
I be very brave all right it's just
clear looks like a hand sanitizer a
little bit it's very thick
[Music]
you know in um Cruel Intentions
oh no when come on I've seen where
they're making out and then there's legs
eyes like yeah this is what this is like
you it's like it's not that's disgusting
it like doesn't break look at that it's
like legit like mucus beautiful it's not
as slimy as I thought it would be snails
don't smell so bad for under eye area
tap is playing the piano to make skin
absorb its essence this is the most
Asian instructions I've ever read in my
life my mom wrote this tap it's like
you're playing a piano oh I didn't do
that I haven't like played the piano in
since like that third grade this is
right I like the feel do you like to
feel I was busy playing the piano in the
piano I'm Keith I feel like it gives a
nice little shine I like it but now it
kind of feels like my skin's getting
tight whoa now no you said that I think
I feel it it makes your skin kind of
shiny I look dewy as [ __ ] and that's
always good yeah I see it looks oh yeah
it looks good the moisture it is the
fewer wrinkles I'm gonna get he's like
the closest sentences ever come out of
any like it like it doesn't feel heavy
because I hate like heavy skincare it
feels like really nice and light I
really like the way this feels
I'm getting that I'm getting that fresh
air scent under my eyes right now it's
feeling really good if someone set me
down and was like listen if you put 96
nails on your face every day for like
the rest of your life you won't age I'd
probably do it because I would do any
probable yeah damn I would I would
definitely do it
I would totally use it again it's very
light I feel like it's super good for
summer too hey man my friend you just
pull a scent on her face there's a
placenta cramp yeah so like I don't
think this is any worse yeah snow
sometimes not that bad don't judge a
book by it's cover and don't judge a
snail bites show all right what if
another
animal came and took our snot and put it
on their skin
they're like it makes me beautiful yeah
we probably wouldn't appreciate that I
mean I guess if we could monetize it